-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing great
tonight.
Now let's get to the news.
President Biden met yesterday
with executives from Apple,
Google, and JPMorgan Chase
to discuss cybersecurity,
where they suggested not writing
the nuclear codes on his hand.
Senator Bernie Sanders
is set to visit
Iowa and Indiana this weekend
to promote Democrats' new
$3.5 trillion spending proposal,
though it might have been better
if he'd waited until
after the harvest.
"Somebody help me find my way
out of here!"
The CEO of Delta Air Lines
said in a new interview
that he won't refer to the new
coronavirus variant as "Delta,"
though I don't think it's cool
that he keeps calling it
the Air China virus.
The Los Angeles County
District Attorney's Office
announced yesterday
that porn star Ron Jeremy
has been indicted
on more than 30 counts
of sexual assault.
Man, it's always the guy
you most suspect.
A zoo in Belgium
recently banned a woman
because she's having
a self-described affair
with a chimpanzee
which is negatively affecting
his relationship
with other apes.
And just a guess here --
hers with other humans?
A luxury clothing brand
that made a cashmere sweater
that read "Cuomosexual"
has offered to restitch sweaters
for customers,
though I'm not sure they came up
with the most elegant solution.
The makers of Mountain Dew
have announced
they will release
a limited-edition
Flamin' Hot Cheeto-flavored
soda,
and the FDA
is already scrambling
to approve a vaccine for it.
That's right, the makers
of Mountain Dew will release
the limited-edition Flamin' Hot
Cheeto-flavored soda,
and fans are giving it
two Tums up.
[ Laughter ]
It works, Shoemaker.
A small plane recently
made an emergency landing
on a California highway.
Drivers were shocked when
a plane landed in front of them
and Harrison Ford
didn't get out.
And finally,
according to a new report,
2020 was Europe's hottest year
on record.
It was so hot, one guy in France
almost took off his scarf.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.